[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 158 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Ock Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick hello Melanie
hello mark I am back from vacation
welcome back thank you very much do you
feel rested I feel I've arrested thank
you for taking care of things while I
was gone
yes well somebody had to keep it and say
it keep it and saying it straight yeah
so he's gonna keep the lights on I
understand something like that yeah we
survived
awesome what are we doing this week
that's a great question what are we
doing this week this week we're talking
to you VP of engineering melody big
vessel which is a great interview really
looking forward to getting stuck into
that and then after that we have our
question of the week if I want to
configure third-party notifications such
as slack or github into my cloud build
configurations how can I do that that's
a great question mark
where did that question come from okay
so cool things of the week let's go
ahead and get started with it yeah which
we've already said that you're back but
I think one of the big things for us
this week and specifically at the
beginning this week we had two million
downloads yes you know crazy Wow
listeners thank you listeners thank you
everyone
thanks to you Melanie thanks to princess
cos you know he's gonna call yes thank
you for incest but also yes good job
mark
yes it's been a little more than three
years and the two million came in a
little bit more than nine months after
the first million took about 12 28
months yeah yeah as long as things go up
into the right settings fine clearly
people like this I hope so maybe not no
so yes thank you thank you listeners
thanks River I know last time we didn't
mention it on the podcast itself it good
guests okay
another cool thing of the week that we
wanted to mention is that our glorious
leader as holden might say is Craig
Wilson from the team he who's been
sharing out this googled cloud
developers cheat sheet and he has
created a github repo now that you can
use to access it he's got a number of
different things on there that you can
use to play around with but it's a nice
cheat sheet that gives you just like
these forward definitions definitions
yeah four words or less so it's not
straightforward
if you want to know
about GCP cloud or firebase or Apogee
any of these things if you have
questions and you don't have to spend a
lot of time reading up on them you can
just take a look at the sheet and it'll
give you a quick summary yeah cuz
there's a lot of things now
yeah there is there's a lot all right
mark you got something else for us I got
some fun stuff so on the open source
gaming front Agana is the open source
kubernetes based game server scaling and
hosting solution that you created yeah
that I started it along with some other
people when zero point six point oh
right now so we just had a release on
that every six weeks that's happening
but yeah that's going along at quite the
ready clip and along those veins as well
open match the open source matchmaking
platform has gone zero point 2.0 release
candidate there's a bunch of new
functionality in there as well there
refactoring a whole bunch of things in
there and it's it's yeah it's turning
into a really nice little platform and
another cool thing we want to mention is
some of the cool things announced over
at the firebase summit there's a good
blog post that covers that apparently
firebase is being used by over 1.5
million apps yeah they've got a bunch of
new features actually a whole slew of
stuff that I actually didn't realize
that was in here one in particular
iOS support for test lab has gone GA
which I am very excited about so far
based test lab is a platform for testing
your mobile apps in real live
environments and now you can do it both
on Android and on iOS which makes me
very very happy
whoo-hoo there's a lot of cool stuff in
here from performance monitoring
enhancements crashing olynyk's being
integrated with hater duty doing more
stuff with be querying data studio lots
and lots and lots of cool things and you
can read all about that on the blog post
so that we will include a link in the
show notes we will indeed alright mark I
think that's it for our cool things of
the week for this week so let's go talk
to melody so I am definitely very very
excited to have melody McPhee sole VP of
engineering here at cloud joining us yet
again on the podcast how you doing
melody I'm doing well thanks for having
me thank you so much for joining us
today I'm looking forward to talking to
you again in case people didn't go back
and listen to the episodes we did it
around next can you tell us a little bit
who you are what do you do what's your
background ah got into computer science
right after college building systems at
a startup and enterprise software I
actually have my Google verse 3 this
week
I'm grass and several years ago I
started working on how to make
developers at Google more productive
where were you know we wasting time how
do we make them happy and its really
been this awesome journey of learning
about how Google has made one of the
most productive and highest velocity
engineering teams in the world and how
do we bring that out to other
communities outside of Google so teams
doing open source development teams
interacting with Android and chrome and
then also developers and operators using
Google's cloud platform so it's this
really awesome blend of sharing what
we've learned internally collaborating
with our partners to be providing the
best services in the ecosystem and then
contributing to open source products
that are already out there the
developers love and care about or open
sourcing things that we feel like the
community would benefit from so what
really motivates and inspires me is how
does my team and how does Google help
influence and improve how software
engineering happens in the world and it
really is about the people you know the
developers all different backgrounds
operators all different backgrounds
getting the benefit out of you know the
work that we've done what are some of
the key successes for you for this year
that you've seen in terms of helping
developers so this was you mentioned
next this was kind of our debut year a
little bit we launched cloud source
repositories it's sort of the next level
bringing code search and cloud build
integration with some great open source
partner work and then have made some
significant improvements in stackdriver
which provides monitoring solutions for
operators we launched Incident Response
in management so that's used by Google a
Suri's as well as operators using
Google's cloud platform so it really is
about this end-to-end experience for
what people call DevOps and the way that
we think about DevOps at Google is
automation around the developer workflow
and the culture so the practices and the
ways in which the humans are interacting
that was a big thing for us this year
I'm pretty and when I look at it it's
like open source great partner
integration you know working with
folks like get lab and integrating with
github and then you know putting some
products out to the marketplace which
has been a lot of fun just a couple of
products not a lot you mentioned
something interesting there too we were
talking about the incident response used
both by external people like people who
develop on Google cloud as well as s
Ari's is that a pattern that we're
looking to keep going with we're like
stuff is but internal external a
bringing stuff internal to external it
is we've sort of optimized internal to
our environment you know you think about
like borg and you think about us taking
our storage systems out into the market
with cloud spanner right great launch
this year but I think there's magic that
can happen when both the internal Google
teams and external teams are using the
same products and learning from each
other like we're hearing input from our
customer teams that were then bringing
back to help us innovate internally and
that's just such a magical
bi-directional sort of learning that can
happen between these communities and my
goal is to have that happen as much as
we possibly can where we break down
walls so that developers and operators
can learn from each other nice where do
you see this going in terms of trends
what you seen so far what do you think
that's going to look like the next year
and beyond so probably heard about this
thing kubernetes well you know amazing
engagement with the community and just
looking at the data of enterprise
customers experimenting with kubernetes
and bringing it into their own Prem
environment so our goal in DevOps is to
have an amazing experience for
containers on GCP this is the theme that
we committed to you look at our launches
around vulnerability scanning around the
support and stackdriver
across the board we want the best
experience for using containers to be on
GCP again in a way that's open and
builds on all the great momentum that's
happening in the community so that's a
trend that I don't think we could have
predicted how quickly teams would be
adopting use of containers in their
business and how they write applications
and how they modernize so that's a trend
that I see just up and to the right yeah
faster than we can predict
in many ways and when enterprises are
looking to modernize their applications
there's some ridiculous statistic very
high meaning in the 80% that they're
looking to use containers for
modernizing on-prem and then as they
come to the cloud so that's a trend
we're fully committed to you shouldn't
be surprising here but I think the usage
in terms of adoption is happening much
faster than we thought it would so we're
paying attention to that we're looking
at adoption we're looking at customer
feedback the other trend that I would
highlight would be go the NGO community
is thriving right the predictions of
usage increase the feedback around
respect and inclusion in the community
is really inspiring to me and just
awesome and so that you know in terms of
Google's contribution and participation
to that community really committed to
continuing to make go a great language
that solves a variety of problems and
works great on GCP the third pattern
that I would highlight would be you know
we started this experiment within Google
to learn about developer productivity
and interesting part about this is that
it has both qualitative and quantitative
so we measure everything at Google right
we're always trying to learn from the
data but there's also a qualitative
aspect of this of how happy are the
humans how satisfied are the day and you
know engineers are tough to make happy
[Music]
and like keep raising the bar spaces at
ten so one of the things that we're
really excited about is bringing sort of
those insights into productivity out
into the market and when I talk to our
partners they're you know we're all sort
of thinking about as millions of
developers come to the cloud how do we
help have them be productive and you
know and maybe a little bit happy and
been able to create and take their ideas
to reality in a way that's a good
experience so that's a trend that I see
us being very committed to in terms of
helping you know developers and
operators on the platform you were
talking a little bit about like
communities and running it anywhere I'd
love to hear your take on where you
think like hybrid cloud is going is that
something you think some yam or or
contracts do
yes so again we look at the research
data we're pretty committed to learning
from our customers again in the mid 80%
enterprise customers are looking to
hybrid cloud they're committing to
solutions that support hybrid cloud
amazing announcement with GK on Prem
right great feedback around that alpha
launch that's coming in from a DevOps
standpoint help the developers and
operators be productive whether they're
on Prem or on the cloud and we know that
customers are going to be making
different decisions around their journey
to the cloud so we want to support them
in that and empower them in that I think
yes and yes it will continue to be a key
priority for GCP and for making
developers and operators happy so you'd
mentioned before I know we talked
already a little bit about kubernetes
what are some of the other open source
projects that you're particularly
excited about that you may have a bias
about that are specifically ones that
you enjoy and inspired by so I will
highlight a pattern that I'm seeing
which is not anything specific but I
think if you look at the pattern you can
see a bunch of really cool innovation
happening so the CI CD continuous
integration continuous delivery space is
really fragmented and so what we're
seeing is either around kubernetes or
around aspects of what developers are
trying to solve these problems there's
these open source tools that are coming
up that are very specific to particular
things that developers need to do so an
example of that would be scaffold which
we talked about at Tokyo next it's
focused on how do we make it really easy
to run kubernetes on your local
environment and we know that developers
want to be portable they want to develop
anywhere so you can see these bits where
hey there's this pain in my workflow I'm
going to develop something that is open
source first that can get contributions
from the community
same thing with mini cube which was you
know something we released a while ago
but I think that part of the ecosystem
is incredibly like creative and
inspiring in that the community is
looking for like solve specific problems
that's grounded in pain that developers
are feeling today
and so I'm sure there's big massive open
source projects that we don't even know
about that are on their way but I think
I'm sort of inspired by that some of the
smaller things that I'm seeing that are
gaining traction that are you know that
are helping developers get their job
done I like that that's pretty cool yeah
another question actually that's come to
my mind where did you start out well I
guess I should say I grew up in rural
California so you know there were
literally eight kids in my elementary
school class like math and science and
computer science were not top of mind
but I feel super grateful that I had
some teachers that saw that I was really
interested in math and science and
through up into college really supported
me and seeking out how to learn about
this area got to college wanted to learn
more about computer science at the
college I went to wasn't a great
community so I studied some other things
I studied biology in history and then
you know kind of was dabbling on the
side and taking classes and learning
more and started my career at a startup
where I was having to do pretty much
everything learn the front end the back
end you know we call full stack
developer that was just that was just a
job that was what you did and then I you
know I started working building
enterprise software for banks and energy
companies and saw what happened with the
bubble-and-bust in Silicon Valley and
you know kind of multiple iterations of
that so it's definitely been quite a
journey of seeing how the industry has
evolved seeing the patterns of sort of
ebb and flow of grounding in the
business and grounding in what users
need and also you know seeing the tests
that have happened there's a big
cultural test I think going on right now
in the valley around inclusion and
diversity I'm really committed to in the
work that we're doing in DevOps creating
the most inclusive and respectful
experience for developers and operators
so if you think about great interactions
and code review and deviate first thing
is there are there any specific things
that you recommend for those who want to
be more inclusive in regards to you know
code reviews and other
types of just bringing people into these
type of things bringing into tech all
that again if we come back to the data
all the data shows Google and many other
tech companies are building products for
a diverse set of users however when you
look at the humans that are actually
building those products it's not a
diverse team right
so we miss things right we miss and you
can look in examples of just missing it
and we need to do a better job like we
need to be explicit and thoughtful about
the communities and the users that we're
serving and I strongly believe that
diversity of perspectives will lead to
better products for the diverse set of
users that we're trying to help and I
think so what people can bring bring
openness bring curiosity bring questions
be respectful and open to different
perspectives listen like we all have a
part to play in every interaction so I
mean here you have this wonderful robust
extensive experience in the space in
general that you're able to bring to how
you view how you lead what are some of
the key skills that you feel like you've
been able to gain over the last several
years in particular that's helped you
really lead and transition more as a
leader and and not as much as a like
you're building but you're leading
others to build now yeah I have had some
awesome allies and mentors that I've
gone to for help that really helped me
check my own you know stories that I
would tell I know I mentioned this to
you before I'm a big fan of brené Brown
yes you have and you know I'm gonna
butcher the quote she has something like
you know sometimes the most courageous
thing we can do is just show up and I
think showing up as who you are is
something that I have learned over the
years in TAC being the only woman in the
room many many times to show up in how I
want to model leadership and that comes
back to caring and kindness for the
people around me and inspiring toward
these big audacious goals that we have
in the world I really believe that we
work really hard on these goals we spend
a lot of time together and the
experience of people working together
feeling cared for or feeling respected
feeling like their
valued is such an important part of
doing good work and when people don't
feel like that it's gonna be more
difficult to accomplish those big
audacious goals so for me the transition
in leadership was embracing showing up
as myself and coming from a place of
caring and kindness for the people
around me and really showing that to
people along with the technical debates
and the details and all that great stuff
like you know we get we can have both
and to bring that full circle as well
I'm guessing that that feeds back into
as you look to developers or people who
use our products how to make them
happier as well yeah so user experience
research right learning listening to
them listening to their perspectives
hearing what's working for them what's
not working for them coming from a place
of empathy of how to help them I really
believe in the more we see the pain in
the products that we're developing the
more focus we're gonna have to solving
those problems which you know to come
back to your point about Incident
Response and management we need to make
sure that we're addressing the pain
points for both our internal communities
and our external communities and that
keeps us super focused on making that
the best experience that we can what do
you like to hack on when you have your
own downtime or I don't know that I'm
getting a lot of downtime exactly but
what do I do when I have like a block of
deep work huh yeah it is about writing
down and then getting at the whiteboard
around the things that we need to be
thinking about a year or two years from
now so really pushing ourselves on the
bleeding edge of what the experience
could be I think there's just a lot of
room for improvement and how developers
write software and how much toil there
is and there's some things a year to out
around how to have the experiences be
more natural more insightful more
intuitive include more automation that I
want us to work on so when I have
downtime I write and whiteboard and
start to put the ideas out there so that
we can iterate on them and strategize
yeah you know you were talking about
Bernie Brown in particular and as a
resources of somebody who's inspired but
when you're thinking about what's next
doing where things are going what are
some resources and people and tools that
you
- to help you get some ideas I turn to
research and internal data and external
data so there's an organization called
Dora which is the DevOps research group
led by an awesome team Nicole and jazz
and jeans who they have been studying
DevOps practices and what makes DevOps
teams perform well for a long time they
just released a report so that's
something that Google helped sponsor and
our big believer in in terms of
understanding the practices so I look to
that one of the themes that came up in
the latest report was security and this
idea of shifting left like how can you
move security closer to code than you
know you're finding a security issue out
in production so we're really listening
to that external research as a way to
sort of think about how we embed
security practices and policies and
automation closer to the code much
farther away from the end user impact
just as an example so I look to research
I look to research internally we have a
great research organization team here
that meets with customers that works
with external customer survey groups and
we do our own surveys so I'm really
looking to hear from people and
understand that data as I'm sort of
processing what's next for us given that
you're doing all that research and you
mentioned security but what what are the
challenges that you're actually seeing
people are having out in the wild well
one is that the toil is so high yeah
okay so it's like how do I know what to
use and how do I create the glue to keep
it all together a lot of pain around
that security is really top of mind so
if you think about the patterns of
open-source usage again up and to the
right enterprise companies are adopting
open-source everyone's using it the rate
of contributions is increasing do we
know what our dependencies are to
open-source we don't have a lot of
transparency into that and that's a
problem Google will help solve in the
community so transparency is a big one
we don't know what we're depending on in
the stack security transparency I think
moving quickly right so I will say
coming back to productivity when I talk
to customers the productivity and some
of their organizations is low and when
you do some debugging it could be
because the teams don't trust each other
right like there's resistance to
releasing software so they have one
release eight quarter right versus ten
releases a day so you sort of dig into
like how do we help teams learn and
build trust but yeah I would say
security transparency productivity
continuing our focus on automation
people are people are struggling with
that and then I think Google can help
play a role in embrace standards that
are starting to evolve in the different
spaces that were that we're working
particularly the fact that you'd
mentioned about people are struggling
with the automation P said it's
interesting to watch because I know I've
seen us moving and these it's and starts
in some ways of like we want to automate
as much as possible but yet we also
recognize there's only so much that can
at certain times be automated and it's
continually evolving but it's
fascinating it's it's fun to watch too
in a lot of ways another point around
that is that more so than any other time
sixty plus percent of developers feel
like they have a choice in their toolset
so the fastest way to make a developer
unhappy is to waste their time they're
gonna pick the thing that makes them
productive like they're empowered right
so if you look at automation they want
the thing that's gonna help them you
know remove that toil yeah I mean
especially when you do anything with
like machine learning and trying to
model ie the last thing you want to do
is spend most of your time just trying
to set up your your system you want to
just get to like in hell if anything and
then also getting the data and cleaning
the data like that's where a large part
of your time will get sucked into and
the more you can actually automate that
the faster you can get to a solution off
of that note I might as well go for this
question since we are the Google cloud
platform podcast
are there any cloud products that
particularly are your favorites you have
a favorite child no I think that you
have an emphasis on DevOps maybe I'm
pretty excited about the contributions
that were making in in the cloud build
space ya know it's it really is a
combination of first-party solutions
that automate and work well in the
platform it's great integration with our
partners there's open source components
of it you know basil we open source
Google's build system has a part to play
in that and I think on the ops side I'm
super inspired by the work that
the team has done within stackdriver to
bring essary tools and practices out
into the external community I spoke at
our cloud SRA summit last week and
there's just so much excitement about
bringing the best practices the insights
right helping people get the insight so
they don't have to go down the rabbit
hole of debugging things or struggling
which really gets to the better business
outcome for those teams right but
minimize the user impact that's the
endgame right so I'm super excited I
mean we have a ton more work to do we're
really excited about the features we're
developing and I think 2019 is going to
be an exciting year if you weren't doing
what you're doing right now what else
would you what would you do I am
coaching elementary school girls
volleyball team and I have to say it is
such a joy yeah
so some clearly different shift in
machine some sort of teaching thing
people making things easier yeah we
talked about this to a degree before but
what advice would you give to those who
are growing their career in engineering
especially in the DevOps space is there
any advice in particular you give to
them because I know it's it's different
now still there's similar challenges of
getting into the space so there's a
couple points that I would highlight
really try and find your passion and the
space you know this whole idea of
purpose and passion when I talk with
engineers that are new to the space are
new and they in the field find something
that really they can connect with and I
think from my own lessons learned in my
career when I wasn't connected to the
work in some way inspired by it things
didn't really go as well very much
relate to the the second thing I would
say is like find your people find the
people that are gonna support you and
challenge you within your team and
outside of your team that are gonna you
know be there to help when you have a
question and then the final thing like I
think it's really important for people
to show up around who they are and what
they have to contribute you know I've
been in these amazing tech design
sessions where
at a whiteboard and someone who maybe
doesn't speak up all the time
contribute something and it shifts the
conversation so be willing to take those
risks to speak up even when you're in
early stages of your career early stages
of building your domain expertise I mean
I think one of the great things about
TAC is we're always learning right it's
always changing and so we're all if we
have that beginners mindset we're all
kind of in the same place we all have
impostor syndrome yes yes we do except
for one of efference except for one who
doesn't right but I mean I said I said
all the time software's a team sport
yeah like sure you can write software on
your own but the fun and the impact is
so much greater when you do it together
and you do with the team that you have
fun and you can look to for support and
so you know my advice would be find that
team where you're excited about the work
that you're doing that you can do it
together
yeah and often that also for anybody
who's considering leadership and
software and tech any advice for them
and specifically just do it we asked the
hot questions here at UCB Podcast only
the ones that make people cry things are
moving really fast so as a leader you
know we've talked just in the short
discussion today about continuous
learning yeah you have to do it right
staying close to your user communities
looking for good solutions because no
company is gonna do it all right so this
combination of first party open-source
partner integration right and as someone
coming into the space as a leader sort
of being thoughtful about pulling
together the resources to create the
best offering for the particular problem
that you're solving and doing that in a
way where you're building a team that
has different perspectives and different
areas of expertise to contribute to that
problem so I think being really open is
an important part of leadership being
curious and then you know investing in
people to build the team because your
job as a leader is really to serve your
team and to provide direction and
guidance and support and so really
embracing that I think is key to being a
successful leader you're talking a
little bit about empathy as well in the
no sense you feel that also has a deep
impact as well in leadership skills it
does understanding what motivates people
and what people care about and what
they're connected to understanding you
people are going through all sorts of
things outside of work
and I think there's a real opportunity
to come from a place of understanding
and empathy as you said with what's
gonna help people be their best self
when they show up at work nice I think
we're pretty much a time but melody is
there anything else we haven't covered
that you wanted to touch on before we
let you go no I want to say thank you I
love the podcast thank you for coming
we're so glad we were really really glad
that you were able to come back and join
us the second time this year so thank
you very much for that if they help us
wrap this up Joe listen thank you melody
for coming on the podcast with us I know
we were really grateful to get time
again with you this year I think you
were only guest that we've had twice
this year so that yes indeed mark that's
our last interview for the year it is
our last interview for the year so the
next one we're gonna do a wrap-up
episode like usual yeah this is this is
almost done for 2018 yeah it is 2018
it is 2018 E&D anyways all right
so question of the week if I want to
configure third-party notifications such
as slack or github into my cloud build
configuration how can I do that
excellent question so cloud builds
really nice so cloud build is a
continuous integration deployment
platform that we have at Google cloud
it's quite flexible in that what it does
when it starts things and ends things
acceptor cetera is it pushes everything
to a cloud pub/sub topic and then you
can listen into those cloud pub/sub
topic notifications so when it sends
data to a topic called cloud builds you
can notify on a variety of things and
one of the easiest ways of doing it is
actually just using cloud functions so
you can hook a cloud function into a
pub/sub notification and then act upon
it so there's actually an example we're
gonna link to in the show notes of
setting up an integration with slack but
you can do anything with it essentially
so if there's an external web hook so
you might want to send stuff to github
maybe you want to send stuff to
something like send grid or mail gone or
a variety of other things in there so
from email notifications to all sorts of
other stuff or just making interesting
things happen inside your system
could do that so yeah clap functions is
a great way to test this stuff out and
get a nice little easy way of building
it one other cool thing I like about
this too is if you really want to you
can do it all in cloud shell because
it's JavaScript it's not hugely
complicated you're usually only building
one function so I actually do that
myself I just set up a little source
repository with my functions in it and
then I just use the inbuilt editor with
cloud shell and it's actually pretty
pretty nice with workflow when you've
been talking about cloud functions you
know what's been coming into my mind is
a duct tape
I feel like Club functions yeah the
equivalent of duct tape I think in the
tech world yeah yeah I I agree it could
have been called duct tape or maybe that
should be our tagline a short phrase
service okay awesome all right well I
know you're getting on a plane soon
Melanie where are you off to yes I am
off to the extremely warm Montreal
complain about my time in Montreal
that's December and how cold it was
lovely Sydney lovely people don't get me
wrong yes it was freezing you're like
nope December definitely going too much
everybody goes to Montreal so yeah I'm
going out for a specific conference and
multiple workshops that are playing out
so I will be at black and AI Latin
xquery I and nur ups all this week and
if you're there please come and say aye
awesome I will be a cool next week I'll
be speaking about organize and looks
like I'll probably also be doing
mentoring sessions on Wednesday great so
if you want to talk about like extending
kubernetes Sierra DS capi machine or any
type stuff building operators any of
that stuff we'd love to chat with you
great anything else for this month sleep
yeah get back over to like that's the
smart way to go yeah I think that'll do
it all right mark I think that's it for
us this week well Melanie thank you for
joining me for yet another week on the
podcast thank you Mark thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]